première astuce privilégiée d'acheter
des articles en haut et en bas des
rayons c'est à dire alors il y a un truc
très simple que les magasins font et
surtout les grandes distributions c'est
qu'ils mettent les articles les plus
chers à hauteur d'oeil donc en fait les
articles les plus chers sont à niveau de
notre vue et donc on a tendance à
prendre les articles les plus faciles à
prendre ça c'est psychologique parce que
ça demande un effort d'aller chercher en
haut ou en bas et en plus il y a des
femmes qui n'arrivent pas à aller
chercher les articles en haut
tu vois ça voilà premier truc
avoir une grande femme c'est plus
économique
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est un des trucs très lourd ça ce que
tu viens de dire 2 faire ses courses le
samedi en fin de journée juste avant la
fermeture pourquoi ouais donc
généralement c'est pas le cas de toutes
les grandes distributions mais il ferme
le samedi soir il faut il y en a couvre
le dimanche mais c'est pas le cas de
tous il y a les articles les plus chers
donc viande poisson les fruits et
légumes frais etc qui arrive proche de
la date de péremption et donc forcément
plus son projet date de péremption plus
ils vont vouloir les liquider parce que
sinon ils vont les jeter ils ont pas le
droit de l'acheter et donc ils vont les
brader et donc il y a plein de gens qui
arrivent au supermarché à 19h 19h30
avant que ça ferme boum tout est en
braderie et les gros les articles
les mecs les deux astuces bonjour c'est
très fort donc vous allez voir tout le
monde déjà il y a plein de gens déjà
samedi 19h30 avec des femmes très
grandes
c'est ce que vous allez voir c'est sûr
et certain après les condés on en a dit
c'est un conseil vous allez voir notez
bien chez vous trois ici de payer ses
courses en liquides pourquoi ouais donc
il y a un truc je sais pas si toi tu
fais beaucoup les courses Cyril ça va
voilà mais en tout cas quand on va faire
les courses on a tendance à prendre la
carte bleue le problème avec ça c'est
que dans notre tête la carte bleue il y
a pas de limite on voit pas l'argent la
réalité sur la carte bleue et il y a un
truc qu'on a enfin moi en tout cas ça
m'est très souvent arrivé je pense que
vous tous aussi on arrive devant la
caissière ou le caissier on a un montant
qui est super à ce qu'on devait dépenser
de base on a notre carte on se dit bon
on va pas dire à la caissière retire
quatre articles s'il vous plaît enfin
s'il vous plaît on va apprendre notre
ego à demain et on va dire c'est bon je
paye sauf que au final on se retrouve
hors budget si on fait ça
tu peux pas dépenser 52 euros donc tu
arrives avec ton billet de 50 tu as que
ton billet de 50 si tu dois prendre des
concessions des choix qui n'est pas le
cas avec la carte bleue
j'adore ce mec j'adore ce mec moi j'en
ai une j'en ai une aussi à vous proposer
ne jamais faire les courses quand on a
faim j'allais le dire
mais tu remplis pas ton ventre en fait
ça c'est court c'est le 4e 4e voilà
conseil faire ses courses le ventre
plein exact exactement ce que vous avez
dit
les grands esprits se rencontrer il
fallait qu'on se rencontre c'est gentil
mais du coup oui quand on a quand on a
faim on a tendance à
en prendre exactement on remplit quoi
je suis en clientèle là 2 secondes
je suis né avec un client je suis à toi
d'accord mais vraiment je suis à toi mon
chéri
il a parfaitement en tout cas il a
trouvé le prochain point c'est fou le 4e
en plus c'est dans l'ordre
cinquième toujours regarder le prix Les
prix
en plus de ça il y a des documentaires
en ce moment qui passent un peu partout
sur ces astuces là où je sais pas si
c'est une astuce mais en tout cas les
grandes distributions pareil elles
mettent des prix au kilo qui sont
parfois
plus élevés que des prix enfin que le
même article si on prenait plusieurs
fois pour arriver à 1 kg
n'importe quoi c'est pas vrai sur les
pattes mais admettons qui est un kilo de
pâte prendre par 250 g ça coûtera
potentiellement moins cher même si c'est
pas forcément le meilleur exemple les
pâtes mais en tout cas vous m'avez
compris je pense bien sûr on a trop bien
compris on n'est pas peu
verse 2 kg exactement ils font l'inverse
bah en fait c'est pas c'est pas un
généralité mais il y a de plus en plus
de magasins qui font ça d'étiquettes
pour montrer le la proportionnelle
inverse le calcul
10 + 2
gratuits
en fait on les conneries des fois la
dernière fois je suis allé j'ai dit je
veux juste les deux gratuits
6e conseil ne prenez pas de caddie ouais
ça c'est pareil c'est un truc
psychologique quand on prend un caddie
plus c'est grand puis on a envie de le
remplir c'est comme tout donc forcément
faut aller avec un petit un petit panier
moi vous savez ce que je fais moi tu
mets la meuf dans le Cali mais c'est ça
chope les trucs
il faut pas prendre de qualité et le
petit truc là comme ça là il faut
prendre un petit panier en fait
il roule maintenant le panier est obligé
de prendre le cadeau tu peux pas
apprendre un petit panier bleu si tu es
célib tu prends ton petit panier bleu si
tu es en famille
sinon tu mets toute la famille dedans
moi j'ai mis ma mère j'ai mis ma mère
mon père dans
très souvent faire les courses avec eux
ils me mettent sur le truc rouge
surtout pas les enfants tu les achètes
sur place
mais c'est bien alors 7e conseil acheter
des marques des distributeurs ça on
connaît c'est-à-dire que en fait vaut
mieux aller dans cet état c'est les
mêmes produits mais voilà c'est la
marque distributeur c'est moins cher
ouais en fait c'est très simple c'est
que quand on achète distributeur ça
passe du producteur au distributeur donc
le distributeur prend sa marge
uniquement sur le producteur alors que
si on achète des marques connues il y a
une étape en plus producteur district
producteur Marc qui emballe qui fournit
au distributeur et le distributeur et à
prendre une marge de 30-35% minimum en
plus sur le prix est-ce que c'est la
même qualité parce que quand on a des
voilà la dernière fois j'avais parce que
voilà on va avoir des mikados tu as des
Mika du c'est pareil ou pas bah après ça
dépend des écoliers les grands
collégiens les exigences de chacun mais
après généralement c'est la même chose
les gens sont assez fidèles alors
produit quand même par exemple moi les
haricots verts je sais que je vais
prendre tout le temps la même marque je
suis sûr que c'est bon et que ça va me
plaire c'est vrai et même si on me
propose une autre boîte un peu moins
cher je vais être méfiant ouais je suis
d'accord après il faut tester c'est
comme tout faut tester un peu moins cher
qui va le qui va le possible
sur les petits pois carottes et montrer
la même usine et ben il y avait un lot
qui partait avec une étiquette bien
connu et puis d'autres marques de
magasin marketing ça coûte cher et là où
il a raison sur les marques de magasins
c'est que quand tu prends la marque du
magasin souvent il y a la carte du
magasin la carte de finalité ça te
renverse énormément d'argent sur la
carte de fidélité directement avec la
carte de fidélité plus tu prends des
produits du de la marque du magasin plus
tu peux te retrouver avec 6 € en moins
il y a un fabricant qui fait une lessive
alors on va la prendre
le fabricant deuxième alors fabriquer
une lessive key une marque voilà une
marque qui est connue etc mais il y a
tout un rayon donc lui il a intérêt
multiplier les marques avec le même
produit sur et s'étaler au maximum sur
le rayon pour garder moins de place
c'est le même produit l'intérieur mais
du coup il a une sous-marque alors on a
un huitième conseil faire sa liste de
courses et s'y tenir ah oui voilà alors
Nicolas parce que effectivement il faut
faire une liste de courses sinon on
commence à vous balader dans les rayons
c'est bon allez remplir les couilles il
y a plus de plaisir à ce moment je suis
toujours maliste
un plaisir d'aller dans les supermarchés
donc franchement je prends plaisir
[Rires]
moi je sais que je suis maligne je mets
l'assouplissant la lessive le PQ parce
qu'il est pas loin
Jean-Marie il est à fond sur les courses
alors et donc par sa liste de courses
ouais mais je pense c'est important et
justement il y a aussi une question de
budget chez des gens il y a des gens
malheureusement qui ont pas un budget
extension et donc voilà pour certaines
personnes c'est facile d'aller faire les
courses etc pour déambuler c'est
vraiment une galère c'est souffrance
d'aller faire les courses et donc du
coup être bien être bien organisé en
fait ça évite tous ces débordements là
et qu'à la fin du monde on se retrouve
avec ben oui le bon budget qu'on avait
voulu dépenser donc c'est très important
9e conseil et c'est ce que disait
Raymond avoir une carte de fidélité une
carte de fidélité dans un massage
thaïlandais
mais ça c'est pareil c'est quand on a
une carte de fidélité bon ça marche
partout mais c'est comme c'est comme
n'importe où dans le sport etc mais plus
on y va plus on est penser les magasins
ils sont plutôt bons là-dessus
généralement on peut arriver à des
réductions sur le même panier de 10 à
15% et quand on dépense 200 euros par
journée de course ça fait plaisir donc
donc c'est important et c'est sous côté
moi je sais que si ma mère elle regarde
l'émission d'ailleurs elle me suit à
chaque fois que tu pourrais peut-être
lui dire à la maison aussi
tu passes à la télé madame vanille on
l'a on lui fait de gros bisous merci en
tout cas me critio à chaque fois que
j'utilise pas la carte de fidélité parce
que j'ai un peu la flemme au final ça
fait des économies
pardon les magasins discount ont aussi
des cartes de fidélité ou c'est que
vraiment les grandes enseignes parce que
je crois que les magasins vraiment qui
sont déjà bon au niveau des poches pas
sûr qu'ils ont des tables
alors Clément dernier conseil allez au
marché c'est pas un peu rastrat d'aller
au marché quand même c'est normal
quand tu sais que tu vas au marché
dis-moi la vérité droit dans les yeux
bon non
voilà mais par contre c'est pas
forcément aller au marché ce point-là
c'est plus aller envoyer quelqu'un au
marché
non non non j'oserais pas faire ça
mais pour acheter des aliments frais
parce qu'en vérité
à la fin parce qu'en fait
c'est comme pour aller faire les courses
ce samedi soir pour aller à la fin comme
ça quand il remballe bah on arrive
mais en vrai c'est vrai que les boîtes
de Nice pareil la voyelle plus tard
possible bah oui bah bien sûr qui va à
4h30 du matin moi je me rappelle ce que
je faisais moi je veux dormir jusqu'à
2h30 du matin
écoute-moi bien mais moi moi je dormais
je me je dormais comme ça habiller mais
tout habillé en tenue avec le gel sur la
tête je mettais mon réveil à 2h30 je
dormais de 22h à 2h30 2h30 je me
préparais frère j'arrive à 3h30 sans
manger je peux te dire j'arrivais tout
le monde était il était éclaté c'est
comme comme au foot quand tu as un
remplaçant qui arrive il est en pleine
de bois les frères j'arrive à 3h30 du
matin frère les autres ils étaient
cramés j'étais en pleine bourse j'arrive
le temps frère j'avais mis des crèmes en
dormant
le Tik Tok de Clémenceau avec plaisir
quand tu veux et très bon oui Delphine
le dernier astuce à la boulangerie parce
que j'ai vu ça hier parfois ils font des
des sachets avec plusieurs petits pains
dedans de la veille ouais ça ça marche
bien ça marche il y a des applications
en fait qui sont dédiées à ça sans les
citer
ou en fait ils font des paniers donc il
y a les boulangeries mais aussi etc on
peut avoir des bons produits
en temps réel c'est vraiment ce qui va
se passer à la caisse même s'ils ont
triché vous voyez à 5,23 si vous le
scanner qu'il est pas 5 x 3 vous avez le
vrai prix et vous avez le montant en
temps réel vous savez vraiment ce que
vous dépensez vous tu disais l'argent en
espèces tu sais que tu as 150 euros ou
140 tu dis bon bah là je suis à 140 on
arrête ça c'est pas mal le scan j'adore
moi je fais les courses avec place